nearly three million people are under a
state of emergency in Mississippi
because of flooding heavy rain has
pushed the Pearl River to historic
levels around the state capital Jackson
around a thousand homes are damaged by
the floods Omar Villafranca is in
Jackson Omar what are you seeing
well good morning the water is actually
starting to recede that's the good news
but as you can see around me some
neighborhoods are still flooded now we
want to show you a drone shot so you can
kind of get a different look at what it
looks like many of the homes around here
are still surrounded by water some of
the roads are obviously still covered by
water two to three feet plenty of debris
everywhere on land and also under the
water and state officials warn the
threat is not over across the state
fast-moving water swept up cars and for
several major roads to shut down
yesterday we met with a rescue officer
from the Wildlife Department who told us
they've rescued stranded people and pets
from the flood some elderly people just
couldn't get out with the water that was
surrounding their homes now after weeks
of torrential rainfall the state's Pearl
River crested yesterday at more than 36
feet the highest level in 37 years and
the third highest ever businesses along
the river have closed until the flooding
subsides County officials gave out more
than 400 cases of water to people that
evacuated in governor Tate Reeves here
in Mississippi says President Trump did
call him yesterday to offer help with
those relief efforts now even though
this water is going down there is some
bad news there is more rain in the
forecast some places are calling for a
possibly up to 3 inches now officials
are just waiting to see what kind of
nightmare that could cause here Tony
watching those weather reports on why
thank you very much